hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about insomnia
depression and anxiety okay
there's a lot of confusion out there
when you look up depression you know
psychiatrists labeled depression causes
insomnia okay and it leads to anxiety
and anxiety leads to depression I mean
it's just like one big ball of confusion
and of course we have a drug for you but
let's just take a look at what the
difference is between depression and
anxiety depression is the blues it's
apathy you lose hope you don't care
anymore you're feeling down okay
anxiety is worry fear panic always
nervous always thinking always solving
problems okay so that's the difference
between those two now I believe that
insomnia if you were to correct that you
would see huge changes so let's talk
about what would cause insomnia normally
light it's supposed to wake you up in
the morning right and then when it gets
dark it's supposed to help you go to
sleep and this is all controlled by the
circadian rhythms are called and there's
hormones involved you have a clock a
mini clock in your brain called the
super chiming nuclei and it's triggered
by light and dark okay
so vitamin D for example when you're out
in the sunlight you get more vitamin D
vitamin D is really good as an anti
depression type thing and that's
probably why the mint a winter's month
people get depressed because they don't
have enough vitamin D so that's one
thing but how many people sit inside all
day watching their computers like
sitting all day long watching YouTube
videos I don't know if you know anyone
maybe you of course myself do I watch a
lot of YouTube but vitamin D will
actually light triggers vitamin D
absorption through the skin but you got
to be outside and be exposed to it now
when it gets dark out which is
interesting because you may be being
you're inside the room and it's all it's
light until you finally turn the light
off so there's no chance for the
darkness to start stimulating the
hormone called melatonin
so melatonin is if you take it as a
supplement it'll start to create some
tiredness because it turns into
serotonin which is the sleep hormone
which is also a mood hormone too so we
have these this is hormonal shift okay
and then even in the morning
there's another hormone that kicks in
that wakes you up it's called
noradrenaline it's similar to adrenaline
okay so we also have other things that
can help you sleep as well and that
would be making sure that you have
enough be one if you deficient in
vitamin b1 you're going to be very
restless you're going to have a lot of
nervous tension you're not going to be
able to wind down easily at night you're
going to be excessively thinking all the
time so that's that nervous energy that
just that low tolerance to stress it's
just it's bate it's basically related to
the adrenals when you're Drina gland is
overactive you deplete b1 and so it's
kind of like you have this slider fight
nervous stress state that you are stuck
in okay so we need b1 the other thing
that will deplete b1 is alcohol and
sugar refined carbohydrates and also
having gastric bypass here you are
trying to lose weight and you get a
gastric bypass and now you can absorb b1
that well so and then that creates
sleeping problems and more weight gain
you name it the minerals that help sleep
are magnesium and potassium and calcium
so those are three minerals that are
relaxing they're calming on the nervous
system where you get these three
minerals from vegetables okay that's the
main source so you want to consume
enough vegetables the other thing that
can affect your sleep especially
urinating all night long would be having
insulin resistance it's like a
pre-diabetic or even being a diabetic so
what we want to do is you want to
correct it I put some links down below
if you have a blood sugar issue I don't
want to go into that right now but if
you have that problem that could
actually seriously affect your sleep
hypoglycemia that's a low blood sugar
very similar to insulin resistance but
what happens is that you might find in
the middle of night you just wake up for
no reason
that's because the blood sugars
and it stimulates adrenaline that kicks
in the blood sugars again it starts to
kind of come back up so try to sleep if
you have adrenaline running through your
bloodstream it's not going to work
and then lastly digestion digestion can
seriously affect your quality of sleep
especially at night let's say you have
dinner and you sit in front of the TV
and you start grazing and start snacking
all the time you go to bed you're
stuffed you think that might affect your
sleep it does so we really want to make
sure that you after dinner you don't eat
anything okay until you go to bed that's
going to actually greatly help the
quality of sleep the other thing is
getting outside to get some space you're
inside all day long you need to get us I
go for a walk walking is the best thing
to chill out the adrenal gland which is
involved in stress and many sleep issues
okay so that's pretty much that will
help you with insomnia now if you have
specific symptom depression the key vibe
the two vitamins that are involved in
depressed states are vitamin b3 and b12
so what I do I like to recommend
nutritional yeast take it in a
tablespoon a couple times a day because
you need probably more but that's those
two are really good to actually pull
some another depression but it also
could be that your digestive system is
so far off you can't absorb the vitamins
let's say you have leaky gut or a damage
or IBS or or constipation those things
could affect the absorption or if you
drink a lot of alcohol that could be it
right there but the B vitamins are key
in depression or you could have a
hypothyroid issue which is deeper it's
it's a bile deficiency gall bladder or
liver or high estrogen from the cycle to
cause a hypothyroid issue I have some
videos on that I'll put a link down
below but I would honestly first start
trying to work on your sleep to get to
sleep better because you'll be surprised
you may have such chronic fatigue that
it feels like you're depressed it's
almost the same sensation so
I would go aft get some energy and then
see if you're really depressed okay
now then you have anxiety that's usually
adrenal the adrenal controls the
adaptation of stress and to the body so
your body is adapting to a stress state
but when the adrenal gland is being
stimulated too often it can almost kind
of put you in a state of stress mode
24/7 almost like you're kind of in a
flight or fight and it could come from
many reasons let's say you're drinking a
lot of coffee you had a history in
college you drank a lot of coffee like
myself math the dosages of high quality
Cuban coffee that was me and I would
just drink tons of it and then all of a
sudden I just started crashing and
burning so you have things that
stimulates the adrenal caffeine will do
it and then also just being in a stress
State being in a bad relationship having
a trauma emotional stress watching too
much of the news will do it
unfortunately in the news is like
constant speculation like always
recycled the same story recycled what if
this happens what if that happens so you
really have to control what you watch
what you're exposed to because if you
sit there and watch TV and then try to
go to bed it's going to be on your mind
so I would recommend turning that thing
off and reading a book the other thing
that what I use for the adrenal is I use
an adrenal night formula and my massage
will be for bed every night I'll put a
link down below for more information on
that now for anxiety
it's b1 b1 deficiency will handle most
types of anxiety so that's a nutritional
yeast again so you could just take
nutrition aleast and kill two birds with
one stone it also is going to help you
sleep as well especially that except you
know that winding down at night
potassium is really important and
anxiety as well because it's a
physiological tranquilizer it's a
calming mineral it works similar to
magnesium but it calms the pulse rate
down its way that you know your
potassium addition is your pulse rate
really high
put your head on the pillow and you feel
that pounding boom boom boom boom your
potassium deficient and you just can't
wind down easily if you have enough
potassium you will be able to sleep and
your muscles will be relaxed and then
just avoid you know like I talked about
on the videos you have to take a long
list of all the people that are
stressing you out and just avoid them
because I have you know I've been in
practice for a long time and I keep
running the same situation where someone
is you start digging deep into their
environment and they're loaded with just
people that are constantly stressing
about I'm like why don't you do
something about it why can't well you
know find another relationship or
something because it's just killing it
so those are some things now
nutritionally I think it's going to help
you and I think change of environment
going for a long walks exercise is going
to really help you but I want to just
kind of mention this this thing that's
happening recently there's a lot of
people put on psych drugs Prozac
medication okay now what's going to
happen in the next couple years you're
going to see a shift to another form of
therapy which is pretty scary for
depression and even anxiety and they're
going to use it under this
classification of treatment resistance
so if the drugs don't work they do the
next thing okay and it's called deep
brain stimulation and I'm not kidding
you that's actually used right now in a
lot of hospitals even there's four
children's centers around bottom
Washington DC right now that use this
therapy on kids
I'm not kidding I'll put some links down
I don't want to depress you any more but
I want to increase your awareness and
what's going to happen what some doctors
are shifting to some are going away from
drugs into even ECT electric shock
therapy for depression unfortunately
that's what's going to be happening so I
want your awareness to be very high and
if you see this definitely object to it
because when they do deep brain
stimulation there's two parts to it they
basically lock up your skull and the
first part is they drill two holes in
your skull I'm not kidding
and then what they do is they put two
wires into the brain okay so that's part
one part two is they put a pacemaker
type mechanism in your chest and then
they can control it remotely and they
run electricity to your brain and
there's actually hardly any Studies on
this okay now there's a builder trying
to pass right now called the 21st
century cure act and basically it's
calling to skip the scientifically sound
and safety testing for new medical
devices okay so they want to slip this
in hopefully they won't get it passed
they flip this in with the FDA and now
they don't have to do testing to even
see it is safe and use it even on
children I'm not kidding
watch the links down below and now some
of you who don't even want to know about
this but I think it's good to know about
it because they're really pushing this
big time there's even a facility in New
York right now but they're experimenting
on kids and it's just it's sickening so
they're going from drugs now to this
electrical device with actually no
studies incredible and it's because the
drugs don't work right so what I want
you to do is get the word out about
natural things that you can do because
what's happening now is there's just no
differentiation between cause and effect
like they don't medical profession
especially psychiatrists don't look at
the cause and effect relationship they
get it confused they say well depression
causes insomnia insomnia causes
depression they don't really look at
cause and effect okay so check out some
links below thank you so much for
watching and I'll see in the next video